WORKING ON THEIR BRIEFS TO
SUPPORT THIS TEXAS SUIT.
HERE WITH MORE NOW IS THE TEXAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN PAXTON.
FIRST OF ALL, LOOK, I HAVE GOT
IT ALL RIGHT HERE, HIGHLIGHTED
ALL OF IT, READ IT COVER TO
COVER.
WELL DONE.
I REALLY, FIRST OF ALL, WHY YOU
DECIDED TO ENGAGE IN THIS.
TELL US THE LAW AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES THAT
ARE AT STAKE HERE.
>> FIRST OF ALL, YOU DID A
FANTASTIC DESCRIBE DESCRIBING
OUR LAWSUIT.
IT’S REALLY IMPORTANT TO MY
STATE THAT MY VOTERS BE
REPRESENTED.
AND IF OTHER STATES DON’T FOLLOW
THE CONSTITUTION, AND IF THEIR
STATE LEGISLATURE ISN’T
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING THEIR
ELECTIONS AND WE HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING THIS, IT AFFECTS MY STATE.
AND SO OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE
THE CONSTITUTION IS FOLLOWED AND
EVERY VOTE COUNTS.
IN THIS CASE, I’M NOT SURE THAT
EVERY VOTE WAS COUNTED, NOT IN
THE RIGHT WAY.
>> LET’S GO TO THE HEART OF
THIS.
NUMBER ONE, LET’S START AT THE
BEGINNING.
ARTICLE III OF THE CONSTITUTION
LISTED A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
CATEGORIES OF CASES THAT THE
SUPREME COURT HAS ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS DOES NOT
HAVE TO START AT A LOWER COURT.
EXPLAIN THAT IN THE CONTEXT OF
NOW THEIR RESPONSE TO YOUR SUIT
EARLIER TONIGHT.
>> SO IT’S REALLY AN IMPORTANT
POINT THAT YOU BRING UP.
IN A STATE ON STATE SUIT, THE
ONLY PLACE TO GO IS THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
OTHER LAWSUITS START AT THE
DISTRICT COURT LEVEL AND THEY
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE HEARD AT
LEAST ONCE, WHETHER THEY HAVE A
GOOD CASE OR BAD CASE.
OUR REQUEST IS WE WANT TO BE
HEARD.
THE ONLY PLACE WE CAN GO IS THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
SO WE’RE PLEADING WITH THE
SUPREME COURT, PLEASE HEAR OUR
CASE.
GIVE US A CHANCE, AT LEAST, TO
ARGUE WHAT WE THINK IS RIGHT.
WE WANT TO ARGUE THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> Hannity: OKAY.
NOW, THE SUPREME COURT HAS
OPINED IN THE PAST THAT IT MAY
DECLINE TO ACCEPT THE CASE.
AS WE WATCH ALL OF THIS UNFOLD
TODAY, LOOK.
WE HAD A DIFFERENT POSSIBLE
OUTCOME TODAY.
THAT IS, YOU KNOW, WE WERE
WAITING TO SEE IF THE COURT
WOULD OR WOULD NOT HEAR THE CASE
AND NOW WE HAVE A BRIEFING
SCHEDULED.
CORRECT?
>> NO, THAT’S A GOOD SIGN.
I APPRECIATE THE COURT HAS ASKED
THE OTHER STATES TO RESPOND SO
WE HAVE A CHANCE, HOPEFULLY
AFTER THEY RESPOND, TO GO TO THE
COURT AND MAKE OUR ARGUMENTS ON
BOTH SIDES AND AT LEAST LET THE
SUPREME COURT MAKE A DECISION ON
WHAT IS THE LAW IN THIS CASE?
A QUESTION THEY’VE NEVER
ANSWERED AS IT RELATES TO THE
FACTS THAT WE’RE PRESENTING.
>> Hannity: THIS IS THE POINT.
THIS IS WHERE YOU GO INTO VERY
SPECIFIC DETAIL ABOUT ARTICLE II
OF THE CONSTITUTION AND HOW THEY
VIOLATED WHAT WE CALL THE
ELECTORS CLAUSE WHEN EXECUTIVE
OR JUDICIAL OFFICIALS IN STATES
CHANGED THE RULES OF ELECTIONS
OR GOVERNING ELECTIONS.
THAT IS CONSTITUTIONALLY AS
CLEAR AS UNAMBIGUOUS ASNY IN THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT THERE IS ONE
BODY THAT HAS THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY AND
THAT WOULD BE THE STATE
LEGISLATURES.
>> IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
STATE LEGISLATURES, PER THE
CONSTITUTION, TO SET THE RULES
FOR ELECTION OF ELECTORS.
IN THIS CASE, THOSE WERE
OVERWRITTEN IN THE FOUR STATES
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT, WERE
OVERRIDDEN BY OTHER OFFICIAL,
WHETHER THEY WERE JUDGES OR
OTHER GOVERNMENTAL OFFICIALS.
THAT’S NOT THE WAY OUR
CONSTITUTION WORKS.
THAT’S THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF THE COURT.
CAN THIS BE OVERRIDDEN BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING THIS?
>> Hannity: MR. ATTORNEY
GENERAL, CAN YOU EXPLAIN HOW THE
ELECTORS CLAUSE IN GEORGIA,
MICHIGAN, PENNSYLVANIA AND
WISCONSIN WERE VIOLATED?
>> YEAH.
IN ALL OF THE CASES THAT WE HAVE
STATES THAT ALLOWED MAIL-IN
BALLOTS IN CASES THEY WERE NOT
SUPPOSED TO.
THEY ALLOWED FOR NONSIGNATURE
VERIFICATION, WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
SO WHEN YOU REQUEST A MAIL-IN
BALLOT, YOU HAVE TO SIGN FOR
THAT APPLICATION AND THEN
THEY’LL VERIFY WHEN YOU SEND
YOUR BALLOT IN ON A SLEEVE OF
THE BALLOT, USUALLY THEY’LL
VERIFY THAT SIGNATURE TO ENSURE
THOSE TWO SIGNATURES MATCH.
IF YOU JUST WAIVED THOSE
REQUIREMENTS, YOU HAVE NO WAY TO
VERIFY THAT THE PERSON THAT
REQUESTED THE APPLICATION IS THE
PERSON VOTING.
THAT’S A PRETTY IMPORTANT THING
WHEN IN PENNSYLVANIA YOU GO FROM
233,000 MAIL-IN BALLOTS TO 2.5
MILLION AND A DIFFERENCE IN THE
ELECTION WAS ONLY 81,000.
THAT’S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE TO
IGNORE.
>> Hannity: WHAT’S FASCINATING
ABOUT THIS SUIT IS THAT AT NO
POINT DO YOU EVEN HAVE TO GO TO
THE AREA OF PROVING FRAUD, WHICH
I THINK WAS PROVEN IN A LOT OF
THESE STATES.
THAT’S SEPARATE AND APART.
THOSE CASES RUN INDEPENDENTLY IN
A LOT OF THE CASES WE’RE TALKING
ABOUT.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE SECOND
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATION YOU
POINT OUT.
YOU RELY ON THE LAND MARK CASE
OF BUSH V. GORE WHERE THE
SUPREME COURT HELD IT VIOLATED
THE EQUAL PROTECTION CLAUSE AND
THE 14TH AMENDMENT AND WHEN ONE
FLORIDA COUNTY TREATED BALLOTS
ONE WAY, THAT WAS CHAD,
SWINGING, HANGING, PIMPLED AND
DIMP
DIMPLED AND VOTERS HAD THE RIGHT
TO HAVE ALL BALLOTS IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA TREATED EQUALLY COUNT
TOY COUNTY.
EXPLAIN HOW THAT COMES INTO PLAY
IN THIS SUIT.
>> THAT EXPLAINS THE WISDOM OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
REQUIRING A STATE WIDE BODY OF
LEGISLATORS MAKE THE RULES
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING COUNTY BY
COUNTY DISTINCTIONS WHERE PEOPLE
ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY IN
DIFFERENT STATES.
THAT WAS PART OF THE GENIUS OF
WHAT THE FOUNDERS PUT IN PLACE.
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY IN
THE STATE WAS AT LEAST TREATED
THE SAME.
IN THIS CASE, IN ALL FOUR
STATES, WE HAVE COUNTY BY COUNTY
DISTINCTIONS THAT TREATED VOTERS
DIFFERENTLY.
WE, THEREFORE, HAVE UNRELIABLE
RESULTS.
THAT’S A PROBLEM.
>> Hannity: YOU ALSO TALK ABOUT
REMEDY IN THE LAWSUIT.
YOU’RE ASKING THE SUPREME COURT
TO REMAND THE APPOINTMENT OF
ELECTORS IN THESE FOUR STATES
BACK TO THE STATE LEGISLATORS
AND EVEN THE MCPHERSON BLACKARD
CASE OF 1892 THAT I WOULD ARGUE
IS PROBABLY PRECEDENT SETTING IN
THIS REGARD AS WELL.
AM I RIGHT ABOUT THAT?
>> YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THIS WAS TRADITIONAL IN OUR
COUNTRY.
IT WAS NOT UNCOMMON FOR A
LEGISLATIVE BODY TO ELECT THEIR
ELECTORS.
WE’RE SAYING, HEY, LOOK.
THE RESULTS HERE, WE CAN’T GO
BACK AND LET THE GENIE BACK IN
THE BOTTLE.
WE DON’T KNOW HOW TO MATCH UP
SIGNATURES BECAUSE THEY WERE
SEPARATED.
IF WE CAN’T DO THAT, WE WANT TO
GO BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
LET THEM MAKE A DECISION SINCE
THEY WERE ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE
OF THEIR STATE.
>> Hannity: ALL RIGHT.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
FASCINATING.